test and welcome to punch-drunk sports
where winners win a special Monday
edition because apparently some dude
named Bill burr is taking our studio not
true it's magical magical is oh that's
even worse
makes sense let me give that a thumbs
down thumbs down t-bo's new things he's
giving thumbs up thumbs down in real
life yep I like that like and disliking
your status live well tech very excited
about having our guest in he's joining
us via the power of Skype on the seat
geek celebrity haka line that's right
seat geek for all your ticketing needs
you go to seat geek use a promo code
punch-drunk and you get all sorts of
tickets you want all the tickets you
want ever in the world you can get them
and you get 20 bucks off with the code
and make Sam's voice sound like that
guys you go see Bill burr at the forum
we're using C key we're all gonna buy
him here we're gonna go see him support
and yell and scream and you don't even
have to be mad at him for bumping us cuz
he didn't L magical did I just bought
two tickets thanks to seat geek our good
friends of sikhi they are always with me
playoff tickets baseball to go see the
Dodgers today for $11 - tickets -
tickets would cost you two bucks with
our code man go get it go to see geek
get those things now but joining us via
the power of Skype he was an NBA player
played in an NBA Finals he went to
Kansas I want to hear all about it
please he's got a podcast called planet
Pollard
please welcome Scott power to everybody
dude we're old brother we didn't say you
are in the NBA but we only have white
guys from the NBA on this show so we
appreciate you black on yet from the NBA
did we have a black on it well what's
got played for the Celtics you're the
your buddy he's real funny Derek
something no he never played it he never
he never made it oh really that's why he
hates all the NBA players cuz he never
made well that's why you asked him to
borrow money Scott can you
tell us a little about your podcast
where they can find it played a part
podcast we're on iTunes we're on
soundcloud and it's hosted by the pros
club you go to the pros club calm and I
think you can download them from there
too
but it's my podcast is is basically
whatever I want to talk about I've
interviewed hall-of-famer Ray Allen
loved him survivor contestant song
because I was on that TV show Survivor
yeah
so we've I've had episodes was just me
ranting for about a half hour but I keep
them short I keep them listener friendly
so people couldn't like listen to all
I'm gonna commute if you got a 15-minute
commute I'd like you to do the half of
it on the way to work and a half on the
way back and then you're done with me so
take a half an hour yeah typically
they're about a half hour forty minutes
I think is my long one just because
about half of them it's just me talking
the whole time I know people get sick of
just hearing me I love here right the
other three people to break up the
monotony of one voice I love it dude are
you gonna ever have Kurt Heinrich on I'd
love to find out what's going on with
that guy's life I would love to find out
what's going on with that guy's life I
don't know he's those Iowa guys they're
they're weird except nick collison he's
cool
nicaya Raef LaFrentz I played with back
in Kansas I think he's just busy buying
up chunks of Iowa real I renamed it
laprincia I think I think you could
probably buy a chunk of Iowa on Groupon
we should get sponsored by Groupon
giving away Iowa I wrote Rowan's could
recruit white guys could he not I mean
yeah he's he could I had some of the
best white guys on the planet he had to
get he had to go west west he couldn't
go east he had a little deal with Dean
Smith so that was why no kidding okay
how legal is that I think it was just a
gentlemen's agreement it's I understand
it's like hey you guys take the East
Coast we'll take the Midwest and don't
mess and I'm sure that there was
occasionally a player that was from one
of those areas yeah it's in general they
kind of stayed away from each other's
territory out of respect for each other
that's fast
that is fascinating you didn't really
ever think about that I mean you knew
certain people recruited in certain
areas heavily you know even you look at
football that's quite common but you
didn't really think about having these
gentleman agreements of like hey you
know stay out of [ __ ] you know
Connecticut or whatever the [ __ ] hey
Scott did he bring up coach Smith a lot
Dean Smith is that a lot and he a lot of
a lot of what he learned he learned from
Coach Smith and a lot of what Coach
Smith learned he learned from fog ow and
at Kansas so it's you know the coaching
tree is it's a fascinating historical
document if you if you put it on paper
just when you start talking to coaches
and who they were influenced by it's
it's not a giant family tree almost
everybody in coaching has worked with
each other at some point or a very did
you ever have a coach throughout your
entire career where you were just like
man I just do not like I got to get out
of this situation like you just didn't
gel my rookie year in Detroit yeah oh
yeah you remember that I I do I do
remember that he got food somebody
somebody got fired halfway through my
rookie year it wasn't going well who
took over for him dog as a person what
who took over for him
Alvin Gentry everybody associated coach
for every team in the league I think
three times he's like the Rodney Peete
of quarterbacks yeah Rodney Peete was
the backup for like five different teams
on the same year and mount up starting
for all five of them he was always a
backup that took over some of the gig
hey so let's let's uh let's get into
your your playing career for those who
do not know you Scott now did you guys
go you got do you guys go to a
championship game in the NCAA tournament
no I get to the final eight my junior
year and sweet 16 the other three years
and that was as close as we got well
that was back when my senior year sorry
that was back when row we I'm still kind
of had that albatross around his neck
right that he couldn't break through in
the in the Final Four
well when you can all your fruit part of
the country
he can't go for everybody well I just no
harder I mean I just think they had some
bad luck a couple of those
a matchups and stuff I love how a Johnny
refuses to admit that my effective
because North Carolina got all the
recruits that Roy wasn't allowed to go
after never imagined back then if you're
like you know like what Western Michigan
or some small school all the big coaches
are like look you can recruit in Alaska
and the Netherlands and that's it okay
kick rocks
thumbs down everybody thumbs down so
what was your Dean Dean didn't go to
California so that is a big wreck so she
didn't get guys out there yep they split
up the country they weren't missing out
on recruits it just Roy Roy had really
good teams I had really good teams there
my senior year we were number one from
start to finish
and we were we only had one loss going
into the tournament we were the best
team in the country by far and maybe one
of the best Kansas teams ever I'm not
shooting my own horn I played with Paul
Pierce Raef LaFrentz Jacque Vaughn Jared
Hass Wow graves were all phenomenal
college basketball players so who
knocked you out returning team who
knocked you guys out Arizona they end up
winning our senior year yeah that was
mild Simon to be later on and Bibby but
that was mild Simon's Mike Bibby there
was one more guy on that team that was
pretty Jason Terry was on the team he
didn't play a whole lot that year but he
was on that team that's how big they
were just they got hot they weren't even
that great in the regular season like
maybe even told me when we were
teammates later and the Sacramento Kings
he was like look we weren't that great
we didn't win the pac-10 it was a pac-10
back then and he he just they caught
fire and they just didn't miss in the
tournament and they knocked us out they
also beat what North Carolina and
Kentucky that year right that was the
year that they beat it's possible I
don't know maybe three number ones that
was a lot of cream in that coffee that
was the beginning of future teams we're
all light-skinned brothers just whooping
ass on everybody right everybody is
light-skinned dude so you go now real
quick about your college years what made
you pick
Kansas like like for me it's like you
hear all these like recruiting scandals
and you know I mean Louisville and then
you know off football scandals like what
made you pick
Kansas and did you get any of that hot
sauce thrown in there like the ladies or
a little a little cash in a car on the
side did you get did you get the good
stuff
I got nothing I got offers from other
schools and actually my sister told me a
story after I retired from the NBA I got
recruited in 1991 and 92 good years
heavily I mean it started before then
but I mean I signed in 1992 with Kansas
but I was getting recruited by everybody
I was a pretty high ranked prospect so
yeah I got a lot of attention and my
sister told me after I retired from the
NBA in 2008 she said you know there was
a school though the assistant coach
called me and said you have she lived in
La Jolla and you know had a job but
wasn't doing great like you know and
they said she had a two million dollar
shopping limit for houses in La Jolla
wholly she could just go buy a house up
to two million dollars water job but I
had to go to that school
holy [ __ ] she never told me until I
retired from the NBA I was like man oh
I've taken that yeah in 1992 would be
worth right now I know yeah I know I
know you can't say what the name of the
school is but does it rhyme with USC
[Laughter]
very hard
George rambling actually was there
stoned he coached my oldest brother and
figured I wouldn't ever go play for him
he was right
actually if it's done in La Joya
probably rhymes with man Diego State
yeah Wow 2 mil that they took a shot at
me too I canceled one trip I was gonna
go to LSU because the rumor was that
Dale Brown he was the coach at the time
he coached Shaquille O'Neal yeah the
rumor was that he was he was throwing
big money around and so I was I was
taking a trip to LSU just to see what he
would offer me in person and I ended up
committing to Kansas and I canceled my
trip to LSU so I never got to hear what
the preacher band was offering but to to
your point about the the hot sauce the
other stuff I was on my trip to UCLA
and they took me to a party and it just
wasn't my scene yeah it wasn't the right
place for me to be and and I grew up
Mormon so I wasn't a real party kid I
didn't drink until I was 21 actually you
know I wasn't a party kid I was just you
know kind of innocent as a kid and so it
just wasn't my scene and I really wanted
to go to UCLA that was that was close to
home it was a blueblood school right and
I really wanted to go there but it just
it wasn't right fit for me the coach and
I didn't get along who was good tune in
at the time very well it was Jim Herrick
it was he was kind of touting that he
was Mormon but then we went back to his
house and there was coffee and alcohol I
don't I don't care clearly Mormons don't
do are you Jack Mormon now because I
grew up in Vegas I found what Jack
Mormon whoa I didn't go I went to
college there and I always loved the
girls who were Jack Mormon they were
like we're Mormon but we ain't afraid to
put a little hot sauce on it you know
I'm saying I don't I just don't go to
church
so I don't know what that's called I
just um my family calls me a inactive
member I respect them but I am when did
you have a real when did you realize
that you had a shot at the NBA I'm sure
when your big recruit you're going I'm
going pro I'm going pro but when did you
realize that there was actually a chance
that you could go pro at the end of my
senior year when my coach called me in
and said all right I'm gonna let you
interview four agents and that I
tolerate he said they're all dirt but
I'll let you do these four and that was
when it became real to me without you it
had always been a dream of mine it was
always something I wanted to do and I
worked my entire childhood and and yeah
a young adulthood to do but I never
never really was like this is gonna
happen
until I started interviewing agents and
and then they started telling me that
what where I was gonna get picked they
were like you're gonna get picked in the
first round I was like now and they're
like no yeah you are and I did all four
of them said that what what made you
decide
I believed between the floors Roy
Williams yeah to answer your question
Arizona took me to a party and I
committed to Arizona based on that hard
what was better about the arizona party
what was so much what was so great about
it have you been there so no I know but
he was also have you been to UCLA the
UCLA party wasn't a scene but there was
something at the Arizona that was I'm
saying what's a difference being the to
LA Mormon duffel bags full of money man
I'm married to a six foot tall girl with
brown skin and long black hair Andy's
back welcome back to the show he got
engaged at the Arizona party but then D
committed and went to Kansas and had a
long-distance marriage for four years
[Music]
yeah it was it was a good party but then
I picked Roy Williams because I knew he
was going to be there my whole career
and I knew that I whether I played every
minute of every game or I didn't play at
all I would respect his decisions and
and his decision-making all for my
brothers and my sister got recruited to
play basketball all for my brothers
played Division one basketball my dad
played Division one basketball and
played semi-pro so I had that experience
in front of me and I got to learn from
them and their experiences in college
and that so that was part of my
education that I just knew how to look
through some of this recruiting stuff
that just wasn't important to me certain
college like the only college I know
that was a big-time college it didn't
recruit me was Indiana and it was
because Bobby Knight just knew I was my
family was more money and he was just
like there's no way this kid's gonna
come here I cost like the like the wind
blows even bother yes he does and that's
fine and I he didn't know I would have
dealt with that just fine it doesn't
bother me I cuss like a sailor myself
but um yeah that's what I knew I was
ballin Pro was not until the end of my
college career
you know it was like when I it was very
similar to when I was getting recruited
because I always was on good high school
teams and recruits
coming to watch people I was playing
with or against and then all sudden
they're like hey well this guy is really
good we came here to watch him but that
guy's good yeah and that happened in
college as well with the NBA scouts the
NBA scouts were coming to watch Paul
Pierce and rapes the France jock fun at
Jared Hess and I'm the fifth option and
then all sudden my senior year I started
kicking people's butts and they were
like wow this kids actually going to be
an NBA player so is there any dirty
is there any dirt you can give us on
Coach K did he recruit you at all did he
slide any duffle bags
anything at all yeah he recruited me
very briefly I actually I thought about
Duke
thank God became that it was just too
far away from home yeah now Coach K gets
all the recruits I mean we all know John
Wooden played a dirty game he like he
well let's just say that John Wooden
didn't actively engage in it but he knew
that boosters were doing it so it's like
he knew but he didn't know and he later
talked about how he's somewhat regretted
that now Coach K he's like just except
for your boy who now is going to who's
the second best recruit in this class
coming in at one point he had the top
three guys which has never been heard of
before how do you get the top three when
you're going right to the pros and it's
just a truckstop also they're the same
decision you're I mean it's crazy
they're both they're all six seven wings
it doesn't make sense
well you in the climate of the top 25
and these programs you're talking about
you have to recruit on top of each other
you have to in and the players nowadays
have to know that they have to know that
there's gonna be three or four guys in
that position and that one of them might
be there for four years and one of them
might be there for six months yeah and
soon as basketballs over they're done
and so I think that the kids that get
recruited by those programs they're told
certain things that obviously get them
to go to those programs despite what you
guys are getting guys in your position
but you know the there's there's
boosters on the side there's always I
made a movie about it actually
oh really called the Prophet yeah
with an F or a pH its profit PR o fi t
yeah I like that yeah but it's well to
play on words because it's it's loosely
based on my life in the Mormon thing so
the Prophet very cool yeah like a like a
religious prophet got it but um it who
did you feel you had to explain that to
which one of us you feel you had to
explain that - was it Tebow was it -
yeah it was it was it like my son which
one cuz you know I got that I don't even
think you heard what he said hey Scott
we like to talk about how to solve this
whole thing it's something we argue
about a lot man Sam what do you what's
what's this optimal solution would you
say for both the players and the the NBA
to the whole I mean getting rid of the
one and done it's probably got to happen
right but what I think it's still
solution I think you should pay that
solution do you think what I think they
should I do die crunch the numbers it
would cost a hundred eighty million
dollars to play every single d1 player a
30 grand a year now that sounds like a
lot until you realize that they've
signed a deal just in TV rights the NCAA
of a billion dollars a year that doesn't
include gay merch or any of that stuff
yeah they're raking in money yeah and
also you and also and also if you are
paying them now now you can put their
names on their jerseys and sell their
[ __ ] jerseys they already do yet they
just can't put their names on it you'll
sell more jerseys with that you know
they're their names on the back they're
gonna [ __ ] themselves man they're gonna
[ __ ] themselves and this G League is
gonna come and steal all the talent good
good yeah well it'll serve the NCAA
right the way that the NBA can solve the
one-and-done problem and then I'll get
to the the NC double-a paying players
say but the the way that the nd NBA can
solve all of the the one-and-done
mentality and actually what would be the
best result for most of these kids lives
because their lives get ruined a lot
most of them not not all of them but
most of them
get their lives ruined because they get
told by some crappy agent oh you're good
enough they go they end up overseas for
a year or two their careers over they
don't have a college degree and then
they're broke and they have no talent
and then they have no there's no nothing
to do and they wind up on the street so
this would save lives and save people's
education and and and have kids more
interested in school here it is their
draft age is 21 unless every lottery
team agrees that if you're available
they have to take you it's a guarantee
it's an insurance policy a draft it's an
insurance policy for you leaving your
education exactly and it's an insurance
policy for the NBA teams that they don't
have to scramble and gamble on every
single kid that leaves after one year
whether they're good or not and they
wait for years for them to develop but
they still suck it's gonna make the NBA
better because you're gonna get 21 year
old men and it's like you used to most
the time and then it's also gonna save a
bunch of kids lives because only 14 or
what is it 30 or 40 Barriss to admit I
don't even know how many lottery teams
are but they're 15 right I think there's
30 though it's either fit no 16 because
16 teams don't make the BR the finals I
mean make those seasons of playoffs
yeah okay so whatever number of lottery
teams if they all have to sign off it
puts pressure on them to know okay yeah
I'm actually going to do this update so
they have to make the commitment to so
it's a double edge that makes everybody
accountable and if all of those teams
sign off that if that kids available and
they're they want him they have to take
him and they're required to wouldn't is
the only way that the best players are
gonna get paid you'll get LeBron's
you'll get Kobe's you'll get the players
that deserve to be able to leave right
after high school and are ready to
become impact players but it's gonna
save a whole bunch of kids lives and
careers but I'm forcing them to think
you know what there's no way I'm gonna
be one of those 16 kids still better
stay in school hey because what happens
there's a lot of those kids that go for
one year they stopped going to school in
spring yeah I'm not even eligible to get
back to school in the fall anyway even
if they wanted to and they don't get
drafted they don't even go to class in
the spring
so they're ineligible to play basketball
hey hey Scott that's the problem
I didn't hey Scott do you think there
are some people though that are just not
meant to go to college like what would
you have like a minor league like the G
League maybe for those for those kinds
of kids I mean not everybody's like
they're not weaved into my my NC
double-a and fix it thing you pay the
players and that's gonna solve a lot of
those kids that are like well I don't
want to go to college because I was one
of those kids that I was broke we were
on government assistance my dad had died
when I was 16 years old I didn't have
any money and I would have loved to have
some money to go to college yeah and I
was on I got Pell grants because if I if
it wasn't for basketball I never would
have gone to college so I knew I had to
take care of business but yes I
understand there's a lot of kids it's
College isn't their thing whether they
can play basketball or football or
whatever it's still not their thing so
how you do that is you abolish the NCAA
the top 64 schools form their own league
they form their own tournament they have
their own football brackets and they
have four conferences four super
conferences and those teams play each
other and then that's the best of the
best playing against each other you know
my big their TV contracts will be oh
geez plenty plenty to pay those players
I also believe is yeah it is like a
semi-pro League and you know if they go
to school great they want to get a
degree
great if not they don't have to go to
school quick question my professional
athlete anyway is you and L being in
that top 64 is you know V if they get
their football program together maybe
well we're going to get some quality but
athletes once we get this Raider state
stadium I promise you that quality black
athletes
I know Ball State's not in that
conversation yeah sorry about that team
that's what you lose there right if you
do that you'd lose kind of the magic of
the Cinderella and what March I don't
necessarily think you need to get rid of
moe
I mean I personally believe that there
should be like a hybrid we've talked
about on the patreon we're like I can
draft this kid I don't think like Scott
Wayne to the league after four years his
body was built for a banging dude yeah
now these these kids go in every Lake
how many of these top recruits get these
injuries that they're out for like giant
chunks of their rookie
because I mean like even Chris Paul
lucky Chris Paul he's if he walked in he
he'd be shorter than Tebow but man that
guy's built like a brick [ __ ]
I need like he's grinding you every
night dude this is a it's not football I
get that but it is a grown man spoiled
and you're getting beat down by grub the
most genetic super freak players in the
world in my opinion are NBA basketball
players and you're getting beat down by
grown-ass men it's kind of like in
comedy we're all in comedians here right
you have people like Taylor Tomlinson or
this new kid cam but Bernard at his name
he's like he's 24 right he's got all the
skills in the world he's got the skills
of me and Tebow but you throw him in a
show with us he's gonna barely survive
because he doesn't have the experience
and that's thing about the NBA they want
Lonzo ball to change the Lakers he's got
the skill of everybody else he doesn't
have the experience to do it yet yeah to
Sam's point let me ask you this Scott
what would have happened to your career
or your body had you gone pro after your
sophomore year not your senior year I
would've been ready I'm still getting
strong you nailed it right there it is a
grown man sport even my rookie year I'm
matching up against Patrick Ewing one of
my childhood
I love how surreal was that how surreal
is that for you your first NBA game and
there's Patrick Ewing there was a lot of
I mean it was really cool when I got
drafted by Detroit cuz some of the bad
boys were there Joe Dumars was yeah Rick
Mahorn was there and I looked I learned
a lot from Rick Mahorn Rick and I are
still friends but there's a lot of those
welcome to the NBA moments but when I'm
guarding Patrick Ewing I'm sitting there
going to him I'm here I made it I'm in
the NBA it was cool and the biggest
biggest thing Rickie's have to do is get
over that real quick or you just get
smoked cuz you're not ready to play when
you can't be stars to get beat up I was
running circles around everybody in
training camp because I was in great
shape I thought then 60 games later
60 games later Williams yeah when you
when you in college you only play what
for now yeah I mean you're playing three
times what your body's used to when you
were guarding Ewing were you like my
goddess man sweats were you like that
was he just like a slip and slide who'd
layup drills with the reinforce yeah who
had the worst Bo
every time you guarded somebody who are
you like it's amazing yeah that Vlade
who's known for flopping no wonder he's
flopping everybody's knocking him down
like get away you stinky bastard now
then this Robin was interesting because
they said the he did wear a cup and when
you posted he posted you up he was like
grinding on you is there any truth to
that really nobody wears the cup get
some baseball yeah okay so you're
running too much yeah it would grind on
my gosh escaping yeah yeah how you do
that you had a 10-year career and it's
an amazing 11 mile hey dude you earned
that 11th year you learn to do man 11
years in the NBA that's tough dude that
gratulations when you think it sound
like dark Oh dark ol mellitus right
everybody calls him a bus but when you
actually look at his career he played
almost 12 years in the NBA like to me
that's not a bus the only bus is Joe
Dumars taking him second and thus
putting too much pressure on that guy
he's going in against Rachid Wallace
Larry Brown had a lot to do with that to
be fair he kind of [ __ ] talk that guy
into the ground darka well yeah well
there it's the rookies and the wrong
coach can go bad yeah they could really
[ __ ] you up but like a 10 11 year career
that's amazing not not everybody could
be kopi like when you look back on it
like I how proud of you that you
actually not you didn't mean to you ever
get drafted and now you've lasted like
11 years that's that's got to be amazed
14 years 14 yeah I see and that's the
thing about Miletich had he been drafted
lower you you guys have got it you guys
are really smart about the NBA I think
you guys know what you're talking about
he'd hear us talking about pornography
you do it's because that's exactly right
he was in the wrong situation for him
and had he not been such a high draft
pick or even maybe in a better different
situation maybe had had a more impactful
career that would have lived up to the
expectation of him a number two pick but
he didn't and still managed 14 years
because the talent was still there once
you get into you're one of 450 people in
the world
yeah people call somebody that's on the
end of the bench a bum like mother I'm
the I'm 100 450 in the world to do what
I do and I did it for 11 years I did it
until my body gave out I couldn't play
anymore they told me know what was your
and so it's it is incredibly awesome and
my kids don't give a damn they don't
they they were like whatever yeah kids
are never impressed with their cool
parents they will be and once they get
older I think probably yeah your kids
are gonna be like eight foot tall you're
almost seven foot if not seven foot your
wife is six foot anything over five
eight is tall for a woman so you're
gonna have like nine eleven kids man
they're just gonna be giant
I never okay possible well different mom
my wife now is six feet tall I get it I
wish my first wife was five seven five
eight oh yeah those midgets ruin
everything
yep well and the thing is she also both
of the women I married their mothers are
from Thailand there's that that genetic
code over there that there's not a lot
of you know I mean I didn't marry yah
means daughter you know what I mean yeah
she of the yeah probably tall up now you
got 11 year career and you could talk
about being and finals in all this but
what was your least favorite season and
why what season could you just not wait
I want this season to end probably my
rookie one in Detroit I mean I really
liked Alvin Gentry III had a hard time
with Doug Collins and the reason why I
like Doug personally but the reason why
is Doug's coaching style was was call
guys out challenged their manhood
especially the rookie we gotta call him
out
to be a freaky trying to be a basketball
player that was one things he said to me
a lot and I was just like you this isn't
working you don't need to call me out
because I'm the hardest worker on the
team at least I thought that and and I
was one of them and so you know that
style just didn't ever work with me I'm
not one of those guys that need a coach
to call my manhood to make me work
harder I'm already working as hard as I
can that's just how I was and so that
season he got fired and then Alvin took
over I was totally different gave me
some more playing time and Doug was was
giving me because we we got eliminated
from the playoffs so then I started
playing some more and that's by the way
that was the only year I was very lucky
at my career from my sophomore year of
high school all the way through my 11
years the NBA my rookie year was the
only season of my whole career that we
didn't play in the postseason Wow Wow
well you're very fortunate one-one until
my last year the NBA oh you won at the
end with the Celtics right I got an NBA
championship with the Boston Celtics
right dude that's so great so you were
part of that amazing Sacramento Kings
versus LA Lakers run which I find
amazing as a king you could be there
could be some bitterness about the
reffing and all that stuff but like what
was that like like first of all I got a
question did Doug Christie's wife have
like some weird kind of blackmail on him
that he was allowed to ride the plane
and was that awkward there were times
where it was a little I guess
awkward would be an acceptable term cuz
she's a really nice girl I'm like it was
a joke it was in no but but it was there
was strain sometimes because we're like
you know this is this is our bus this is
our plane you know and then he goes sit
in the back of the plane with her or
he'd go sit on the other bus with her
and then we're like okay well you know
now you're not being a good teammate you
know and so there were some very little
issues with that but Doug was such a
great teammate otherwise except for
those few little things and that was off
the court stuff so we just discounted it
because it wasn't on the court stuff
nothing affected him on the court you
know I used to make fun of their
relationship
to me you know it because it's just it
wasn't the way I would do it and that's
just fine but it works for them they're
still married I got divorced from my
first wife so why would I make fun of
them when they're not married and I got
divorced from my first wife because I
was a bad husband right and I'm not now
I'm a good husband now and I'm more like
Doug you don't have to convince us Scott
you don't convince us what we believe
you you don't have to convince us did
you we know you love your kid what about
Chris Webber how'd that go in prognost
ooh me about Chris Webber because like
what a transcendental feat talent he was
he didn't get in the Hall of Fame this
year I believe that he's a Hall of Famer
without a doubt I mean he it's literally
the only time the Kings have been good
is when you guys and Webber were there
like what was he like like when did you
realize like okay I'm a talented guy I'm
a I'm a first-round draft pick and then
you meet like somebody like Webber
you're like whoa this guy is just
another level event okay tell or maybe
you guys are the same town I don't know
no he is actually the most gifted player
I ever played with I played with LeBron
I played with Kevin Garnett I played
with Paul Pierce in college and in the
pros really but but Chris could do
anything on a basketball court and make
it look easy
now there's guys they're better than
Chris Webber I'm not saying that but I'm
talking about the ability to just go I'm
gonna go block five shots tonight I'm
gonna get 15 rebounds tonight I'm gonna
lock down my guy tonight or I'm gonna
score 55 points tonight Chris could do
any of that stuff he could get 15
assists he was a smooth passer he could
dribble the ball up the court he could
guard anybody he wanted to now did he
take nights off absolutely everybody
that plays that many minutes has to take
some nights off so he wasn't my favorite
teammate but it's funny you guys brought
him up I just saw him last night he was
doing the game here we went to the game
in Indiana and someone over it saw him
we'd caught up for a little bit it was
great to see him but seems like a funny
guy he seems like a funny guy yeah he's
a really really nice guy and just he he
was a good teammate he wasn't my
favorite teammate
who was just because who was oh probably
flaw t-nut it was a great teammate he's
a lot of fun Jason Williams was a blast
I love just talking about him the other
day [ __ ] him he's got a 15 minute he's
got a 15 minute highlight reel on
YouTube that is how has he forgotten
everybody forgot for like a four or five
year window he was so electric yeah I
think that's why I gotta tip around too
much or short bright bursts unbelievable
highlight reel it doesn't even feel like
15 minutes either it feels like a
three-minute video what the thing about
him is his practice a practice and it
would be it would blow your mind even
more really in practice he was
ridiculous because that's what he would
experiment there is and so he would
experiment and the things he did in
practice just make you guys laugh as
magical did you guys soul arias - do you
guys rip him for getting the black
panther tattoo which is the first tattoo
when you walk into a tattoo parlor it's
like it's under four idiots did you give
him [ __ ] about that
no but Vlad II had a panther Wow he's
like Pete Maravich I mean that's some of
those passes I'm saying oh my god so uh
Scott he was practicing all that
shouldn't practice like what he sit
around like and try to sling it behind
his back and stuff would you see him was
he one of those guys that spend extra
time practicing all that stuff I think
that's what I mean like why himself like
yeah that's what I mean cuz like you get
yeah like Pete Maravich had all these I
don't know if you've seen that video but
he had all these old weird drills that
he would do to practice these weird
passes and stuff but you're saying he
just kind of did it during any practices
like that I've seen those videos that he
did if he did anything like that he did
it on his own time I never know I'm just
working on stuff against the wall or
anything gadget you gotta be dribbling
down the court and all sunny lift his
jersey and throw the ball behind his
back and inside his jersey and that
would be the crossover hilarious that's
great
who would you describe as you're not
necessarily rival but who did you always
hate matching up against who do you
think maybe had your number every time
you guys
who like really got you hyped up when
you knew you're gonna be guarding that
guy all night hated guarding yep I like
Gordon everybody I Shaq wasn't fun but
it was a challenge I'm bad and so that
that was be the one that I got most
excited to play against we played
against each other a lot too you know
you guys mentioned it we play against
each other in the preseason in Vegas
then four times the regular season and
then seven games in the playoffs so we
were familiar with each other we see
each other a lot and you have a
correlation shapour was he super
competitive and he was like [ __ ] you
Scott Paulo why don't you have two teams
of your name you [ __ ] suck one to me
cool actually I think if I had a
different personality I would he would
have taken swings at me because my job
write him down and do it and I think he
respected that about me that at least I
wasn't trying to hurt him I never would
try to hurt anybody but there was times
where you know I got a hang on him I got
a foul him and then you know help him up
or whatever but you know he dunked on me
a lot and and you're not alone yeah he
ducked down every dunked on everybody
who was at least it wasn't Tony Parker
dunking on my face
that's true who was a dirtiest player
you remember playing in the NBA who
that's crazy
breaking news no are you like brilliant
or was it like blue hi yeah my teammates
warned me they're like cover yourself
get you and sure as [ __ ] man I went over
to set a screen on him and he just went
BAM
as soon as I went over and tried to hit
wow that was every time a lot of time
you had to be careful around him he was
and again it was sneaky it wasn't trying
to hurt somebody laugh injure somebody
just knew an advantage yeah give you a
charley horse and a leg or hit you in
your nuts you always hurt bird you think
about it
you hurt Larry Bird was dirty as well
Jesus tell me you guys are both Mormons
what is he doing
goes against his code it goes against
the code of Utah bro um so I want to
talk about two things you're you you
were part of or known for obviously is
the vlade divac's
tap which goes to the one guy and the
planet you don't want the ball to go to
in that moment which is Robert Horry who
just hits it it's a it's a one of the
like unforgettable moments of of the NBA
what it what explain explain what felt
to be on the other side of that well
that was a that was a rough game we were
leading from I think starting to finish
we were we were ahead that whole game
and when the every big man is taught
from childhood well used to be I don't
know if they do anymore now they just
teach him to shoot threes but used to be
that when you were a big guy you would
get taught if if there's a rebound
getting close and the clocks getting
expired and it's you don't want to
you're not trying to tip it in your turn
it you tip it away you get it away from
the basket because it's a lower
percentage shot you get you so a lot I
knew that and he did exactly what I
would have done Shaquille O'Neal's
trying to get an offensive rebound and
smash it on your face so you tipped that
ball away from everybody as far as you
can and yeah it just went right to with
the big shot Rob and Rob knocked down a
big shot I mean it was like it was you
didn't even have to reach down they were
watching him right into his hands it
wasn't like it was to his feet and he
had to take a dribble to get back every
point line yeah that was bloody standing
there
it was Vlade yeah that's crazy it's
funny we just watched the whole video
and you just did play-by-play perfectly
for it yeah I I imagine that has
repeated in your head like a loop so how
long does it take you to get over
something like that
how long does it take you to get over
something like that that team that was
the longest part of my career with one
team I didn't want to get traded from
there I got traded there against my
knowledge and against my will I got
traded out of there I mean and and those
I loved my teammates I loved the city of
Sacramento I'm ready to spend my whole
career there
underrated City I don't know why I
always think that Chris Webber saying it
didn't have any good soul food kind of
hurt that that city in terms of with NBA
players I love going to Sacramento I
love doing stand-up in Sacramento it is
one of the my I'm the women are gorgeous
the town is it's like it's like a giant
little city
that's a Indianapolis you know yeah I
mean there's no good soul food there
that's true but where's the good Mexican
restaurant in Salt Lake City I mean yeah
there's certain places that you go for
certain types of food is what I'm
getting at right there are places that
have great soul food and they're not in
the Midwest they're in the south that's
where you get them and there's one good
place in LA but you know that that was
just one thing that was said and blown
out of proportion Chris like Sacramento
as far as I know anyway but but I do
miss those days those were those guys
are guys that every time we see each
other like I just said last night saw
Chris hadn't seen him in years but it
was like we had just been hanging out I
mean it was big hug and how you doing
how's the family all that stuff so it's
it I'm never gonna get over not winning
a championship with that team is that
the is that Sacramento team the greatest
or at least top five race teams not to
win a ring oh yeah they got to be up
there that was a really good team even
with Jason Williams before we got Mike
Bibby we had Thunderbird backing up
people we had John Barry coming off the
bench
we dealt and then they got subbed out
and got Hedo Turkoglu
kidding me that guy had a 15 year NBA
career and should have been an all-star
more often he was he always
underachieved I think for his talent
level but I mean we had great players
off coming off the bench in addition to
having that starting five that was just
magical and moved that ball so quickly
and so efficiently with each other and
then the bench bob came in and we played
a different style of basketball so other
teams it was like they had to practice
for two starting fives right you really
had a one-two combo that was ridiculous
to deal with for other teams it's
probably Clyde Drexler as Portland teams
up there
Utah of stock
Malone the Kings Shaq and Penny never
won once got style didn't work they went
but they didn't win yeah but they
weren't around that long
patch viewings uh New York Knicks and
most likely probably Barclays sons are
probably and they're all it's funny to
allow them with the West Coast teams but
those are probably my top five never to
win it that's those Sunstein's were fun
teams play that would say NBA jams with
NBA James jerseys dude those Suns
jerseys were killer I mean they I want
to get into go back to those they really
should they were just beautiful before
we get in the modern I don't know get me
started about the Phoenix Suns I thought
was an embarrassment to the NBA to have
the Suns on national television cuz it
was just bad bad YMCA rec ball they got
blown out every time and it's just like
hey Suns stopped drafting Kentucky guys
we get it you you like these
one-and-done students but they have no
skills and his great as Devin Booker is
and he's wonderful you're just you're
just getting the same guys but I want to
get into the one thing the do drugs kids
cuz listen you're on a podcast where two
of us are recovering alcoholics and drug
addicts and and did you think when you
did that did you have any clue it we get
that big I feel like it was a joke that
just got away from you in it you know
and it was you guys be in stand-up
comedians you know you tell jokes
sometimes they're good ones sometimes
they're bad ones and sometimes it's the
wrong audience and what it was is
throughout my whole career and this is a
fact ask anybody that works in a crew if
you happen to run into a camera guy that
was working those games people always
ask me a tell a joke the guy the
producer in the truck that went to
Missouri so tell him and I'd be like oh
yeah they love children
you know yeah I knew were the guys do it
was the nineties you could do pedophile
jokes back then and that was that was in
pedophile jokes go on yeah yeah all the
time you know but so it was a common
thing time outs whatever slow part part
of the game whether I was in uniform or
not
this game I happen to not be in a
uniform I was in a suit because I was
injured and you know the guy comes up to
me the camera and he's like you know
motioning like say something for the
guys in the truck so I just go hey kids
do drugs and I look lights on the camera
it wasn't just for the guys in the truck
it was actually on TV so it was a joke
and it just wasn't a good joke it was a
bad joke from is fun stand-up comedy
laughed and it would never have been
made a big deal but when you're in the
NBA it's so conservative right and they
have drug tests right all these guys at
failed drug tests are sitting there at
the read to achieve event reading the
kids never failed a drug test never did
drugs and never got caught with a DUI or
any of that stuff
don't have a problem with any of it and
I'm you know yet
I hope haha I wouldn't I don't say never
I cry pretty good about yet that making
good intelligent decisions especially
when I have so many people depending on
me but you know everybody makes mistakes
but up to this point of my life I've
never failed a drug test and and and I'm
sitting there going hey I got kids it's
a joke well you know sorry is a bad joke
but I'm not apologizing for saying it
because I didn't mean it
yeah it wasn't that what NFL player just
got in trouble for that 11 years later
with the gun let me ask welcome no let
me ask you something yeah jay Feely that
to a while know that was with the gun
and I know and it was a joke about his
daughter and it's only the problem with
this got funny
it is funny yeah now everyone's jumping
down and start it's like dad making a
joke the problem I have with that is
that everyone's calling this guy I'm
listening to sports talk radio I'll hear
and they're like it's bad with all this
innocent time I'm like have you asked
the rock to apologize for every movies
done would go have you asked every CBS
FOX NBC show that has guns it's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life
it's the hypocrisy many gun jokes are in
movies like guns accidentally going off
um it's so stupid that's hypocritical
yeah absolutely
let's get into let's get into the modern
right now
do you like modern MBA do you think do
you prefer the old Ewing like the New
York Knicks Chicago Bulls Detroit
Pistons hanging a bang um you know type
of offensive or do you like the game
that now with a little year-old flavor
to it
ball movement shooting like we're
getting away and I always want I always
felt like this Michael Jordan is
Shaquille O'Neal I thought were two of
the greatest players ever played game
but they also did a lot of damage to the
sport in my opinion in that they forced
the league into a certain style play
Jordan was you know individual score
it's all about me and then Shaq was and
I hope this says of you know me include
you but that get these guys in there the
hack and Shaq and it became these really
big guys that were just there to hack
Shack get rebounds and SWAT shots do you
or do you like this new NBA where it's
like everybody has to be a shooter
that's his question I don't even know
what you're asking anymore and you said
it you said it differently than I would
but you said that players like Michael
Jordan and Shaq force the league to
change
I consider it there they're the best of
their trade and they force people to
change the way that the game is played
because everybody emulates them look at
the Warriors they've they had success so
everybody's trying to be like the
Warriors back when Wilt Chamberlain was
playing yeah everybody tried to gear up
with a big guy of their own to try to
slow down the will there's still and so
it's jazz music it's always gonna change
and it always has I enjoyed this better
than those half court Smash Mouth
basketball that's boring where you walk
it up the court and Pat Riley's call in
a play and there's five seconds on the
shot clock and they finally do something
I don't enjoy the NBA when it's the
final score is 75 to 70 people score it
I loved playing for the Sacramento Kings
because
we we put down 120 points on the regular
and it was a lot of fun to play and it
was a hell of a lot of fun to watch
because we had sold-out arenas across
the league at home court a lot of them
because our fans were we had people that
loved us all around the world and so
it's an exciting type type of basketball
and I think we kind of were that
precursor to the Warriors model now with
the way Vlade and Chris can I can see
that passing big man I could see that
and the ball around screens teamwork no
one cares who gets all the points no one
cares who gets all the shots because
everybody's gonna get that night once in
a while whenever that the other team
gives one guy a rough night on defense
and he's not having it boom the next
guys getting it so the splash brothers
out there doing it it's not my favorite
I prefer a little bit more control five
positions instead of four around one
yeah and everybody's just setting
screens on the perimeter I hate watching
Myles Turner in the playoffs right now
standing out at the three-point line
when there's no one on the whole frickin
court that can guard him in the post
right he's fly out there the three-point
line waiting for a shot and I'm going
coach but in the post and go to work
you'd have 15 points in the first
quarter no they had Kyle Korver kidding
me and you're not even taking that
little mouse to the house that is the
evolution I believe that's the next
level is where now you got all these
shooters but then you're gonna have a
Shaq type come in advance gonna be
inside and outside you're gonna be able
to Dowe bang somebody down low but then
step out if they give you that and hit
the three I think it'll be a four it
maybe even a four that can really that
is true he can go inside and out Anthony
yeah to a certain extent but DeMarcus is
more powerful inside but you can go back
to the basket all day long if you want
it to be any can also shoot threes all
day Noah Davis token Davis but it's the
game's always changing and it always
will and it will take the next Shaq
Patrick Ewing whoever you want to say is
the next big guy that's gonna make the
game go inside and out again because
DeMarcus isn't gonna be that guy but
when there is another big guy that it's
just Yao Ming type size immovable object
that can give
thirty if you don't put somebody big on
him then yeah it's that'll change the
game again real quick Scott we're gonna
our our next our co-host is joining us
in I think he's in Europe are you
pleased pumped did we just lose Scott no
re there he is
re welcome to the show your bed your on
with our good friend Scott Pollard NBA
veteran loves the Raiders oh yeah so are
we wake you up yeah I think he's in
Europe I'm not yeah no you don't wake up
okay where you at guy you those your
[ __ ] there Elbert no Walker Bush Walker
chicks we're God I want to ask you
something now that we are we're talking
with NBA we're talking about what it's
like to be in the a me I want to know
you were talking about the fans in
Sacramento when you're with the Kings
what's the craziest thing a fan ever did
was there ever a time where you like man
this is creepy or this is really weird
there was a lot of those in Sacramento a
lot of that we got treated like rock
stars there and it was a unique
experience for me to be treated like a
rock star where everywhere you went you
go sit you know at a restaurant people
are banging on the window like hey you
know and and people following you into a
nice meal like I don't mean to bother
you but you're clearly alone with your
wife having a nice finally trying to be
you have some quiet time for an
autograph but that's a part of it and
I'm cool with that but you know there it
was just a lot of it I wouldn't call any
one particular situation now I've signed
a lot of body parts if you know what I
mean yeah that's fine yeah now um real
quick what are your thoughts on these
playoffs cuz they're pretty I think
they're some of the most exciting in
years because we don't really know who
could win it I mean we we think the
Warriors if they get back hurt but now
he's probably gonna be out for this
round as well so I think it's why I
think the East is wide open it does not
look like LeBron James is going to be
guaranteed to get to the finals and then
you got the West there's a bunch of
teams I find very interesting what's
your thoughts on them
well my thoughts are on a naked dude
right now I kind of want that image off
my screen
welcome to punch-drunk don't even ask
for it
Joe dammit don't ask boy I didn't know
we were doing a podcast on a bush yeah
we're the number one naked
bogey just went back to playing
Australia he just went back he's now
playing in the Australian Basketball
League re Congrats on your Pelican sorry
is a big pelican fan and they look great
right now in the West and the East while
I hide it wrong a lot of people like all
the Warriors gonna walk through them I
think if you go player four player it's
a lot closer than people think that pick
up of that kid for that young man from
Chicago Miletich is that his name or
what's his Marie oh Chooch yeah mutagen
yeah something like that
he that's a maze that guy's grabbing
like 30 points 20 or 15 rebounds that's
a big pick up man
and he got drew Holliday who's finally
like gotten over that knee problem they
got a good team in Rondo's got
experience I don't think it's gonna be
as a walk over like people think it's
gonna be for the Warriors I think that I
think fun to see a Meritage IgG fan of
not knowing who's gonna win because when
I was in the league you'd see some of
the playoff games series and you say
Memphis would be playing
the Jazz or whatever I'm just spitting
names out not current or then yeah two
teams would be playing and you know
neither one of them is gonna get past
the next round it's just like they're
playing that series so that one of them
has to lose the next round
yeah there's no way they have a chance
of getting in but one of them has to go
to the next route and that's not true
this year I agree it's a lot of fun to
see that there's that much parity in the
NBA playoffs right now well you know
last year like Houston was like going to
like game I think it was game six or
game seven with with the next round
being the Warriors and dude uh James
Harden didn't even show up almost at the
point where people thought he was
throwing the game because he knew the
next rounds like why you go play your
your ass beat huh oh yeah real quick one
catching up oh sorry
re real quick why catch you up with the
highlights of the podcast so far NBA
veteran Lemonier NBA veteran Scott
Pollard said I really know my MBA stuff
so just let you know where we're at he
said I really know my MBA Ashley said
the show does take credit for it
Scott to you are you the kind of guy
that because I found I've you know
randomly times I met a couple people
that played in Super Bowls and different
you know athletes and whatnot people
that want college championships and you
either wear your ring or you display
your ring are you thick what do you why
do you kind of guy where's your NBA
championship ring around or do you have
it like on display at home like a trophy
maybe a tattoo of a [ __ ] stamp in the
small of your back you got that but my
my NBA championship ring right now is in
a safe hmm we're a rental house and
we're almost moving into our new house
we're building a house so we're gonna
move into the new one it'll have a case
and a display nice but right now it's in
a safe but you never wear it out yeah
cool it's actually got a loose stone
right now though so I'm keeping it so I
can send it back in and get fixed so who
do you like first
did he really private no bags come out
of a carousel the equipment people go
get the bags off the plane and put them
on a bus that we don't we don't go
through public tournaments looking
mercial terminal you just ruin our
credibility [ __ ] Ari there's there's
gambling on the plane I on every team I
played on we play
in between Lucy whatever Acey deucey if
you want to call it that oh yeah and
some guys played poker that's what we
call our castle - what would you think
what would you do to somebody who
refused I don't remember anybody just
being as aggressive but I heard lots of
stories about Mike hey Scott what would
you do somebody who what would you do to
somebody who lost a bet though but
refused to pay that's you're gonna lose
the respect to your teammates real quick
and they're like I'm fine with that
I'm fine with that what if what if you
are one bad and the other guy owes three
bets and the other dude oats two bats
but you haven't they want you bare of
your bag first and that's some [ __ ]
they should pay off their bets first
would you agree Scott and I'm a Raiders
fan sounds guilty that's what got you
into the trouble in the first place yeah
yeah
Scott I'm gonna ask you something who
was somebody in the NBA like throughout
your NBA career that was like a huge
partier and then you'd always be like
how is this guy even gonna make it to
the game tomorrow and then just shows up
no problem everything's fine absolutely
got drunk before the games
Vlade Divac before the game oh yeah I
read out they all get huh I always heard
that consider that a performance
enhancer I don't think it hurts
anybody's performance totally the one
guy in particular that until he passed
his fourth drug test
he was drunk all the time because he
needed it to calm down and then he
passed his fourth drug test and then he
would smoke weed and he was the best
teammate for the rest of year Wow it was
like he needed Jay Williams be a great
teammate of course yeah I respect that
their story I always hear yeah
I mean those guys that had problems and
there was guys that had all the talent
in the world and they had real problems
like it wasn't just like a beer or two
and then you know to mellow out and then
go out and play a basketball it was like
hammered drunk and then you go out there
and get in a fight with one of your
teammates and warm-ups and coach throws
you out of the game those guys don't
last of the end behavior yeah out of
hammered before a game medic line is way
over there so who's your favorite play
right now in the NBA
my favorite player in the NBA right now
I mean there's some great ones I'm torn
I'm torn but it's gonna be a big guy you
know that
yeah I'm torn between Anthony Dubrow and
porzingis is actually my favorite but
he's hurt a lot so I'm worried about his
body but and then Joel embiid of course
he's a Kansas guy I think of all of the
current NBA players he has the most
ability to become one of those guys that
is talked about in 50 years
yeah it's great absolutely hilarious
I think he's great Greek freak remember
everyone says like LeBron was like a
once-in-a-generation player now we have
the Greek freak Kevin Durant
we are Ben Simmons they're all very
similar it's just like presume the NBA's
just gonna be all seven footers where
where your hips fall it determines where
you play if you have like lower hips or
higher hips you're gonna be a download
guy if you have lower hips like Kevin
Garnett was the first guy that was
seven-foot built like a guard like he
could move like a guard we hadn't seen
that before
Ralph Sampson yeah he was a shooting
guard that got shot with a ray gun yeah
you got gamma radiation Ralph Sampson
was like that and he was you know he he
brought his niece because sometimes guys
that he didn't play perimeter as much as
the people we're talking about now
Sampson still bang down low for the
majority of it you're talking about you
know Durant could bring them I mean a
Garnett could bring the ball up and just
pull up a [ __ ] three point jumper in
your face what was it like taking on
Garnett I heard he was nasty
we did not like each other why our whole
careers until we were teammates and and
it turns out like a lot of guys I hated
playing against like Reggie Miller was
one of those guys - because competitors
compete you know you hate that guy
because he's competing his ass off well
that was how Kevin felt about me and
that's how I felt about Kevin we got one
of those NBA fights one year my point
push the Wolves and I was playing for
the Kings where you both don't really
want to throw a punch but you do so you
let people standing between you white
boy push white boy push oh yeah
who was the best [ __ ] talker but Charles
Barkley oh oh did he just make you
laughing the top is really great Sam
Cassell was really good too you got to
talk [ __ ] if you look like that
I can hit him yeah he looks like he's
here to see our leader take me to your
leader
brick re all right what's great in
California would you pass that fourth
drug test
just be like guys back all right
breaking news we have breaking news with
Ari Shaffir earlier let's see if I can
guess
Scott told us who he thought was the
dirtiest NBA player when he was playing
who do you think it is did you play
against that guy from Detroit they
[ __ ] lamb beer no no no I'm not that
old dick
[Laughter]
let's see yo you're never gonna guess no
I don't know who John Stockton Stockton
really I know how much surprise - yeah
you apparently would don't you in the
balls all the time you set a screen no
he doesn't have any friends over
mourning for the cops Pollard is a
Mormon
not practicing non-practicing that's
like saying Carl
as a Mormon just cuz he played for the
Jazz is okay I was about to stop pause
Mormonism is like Jason Tebow's you like
one W when you go set a screen at a mall
every time so you gotta be ready for
that right in the neck grab your girl
you grab your Jersey and hold your
Jersey and and box out so you come in
and stick his hand right up your crotch
or whatever come behind Oh like relaxes
can see with his delicate hands hey
Scott who wins the funniest joke comes
from the non comedian well played so
well play who do you think wins the
championship I think that the Rockets
get out of the West this year because
it's it's time and I think that the
Raptors fight right now I love the
Celtics and I want them to do it but I'm
really I'm hoping for the I hope and I
think it's time for the Raptors as well
and I think that's gonna make for a
great finals and I don't know who's
gonna win if those two get there it
could be either one of them I think
it'll go seven games and it'll come down
to a last-second shot in Game seven but
I'm hoping that Houston does I think
Houston's better but I wouldn't mind if
either one of those teams one I walk I
just follow [ __ ] I would Eddie - I
don't want Golden State now Scott you
have a Raiders head on big Raiders fan
like myself I've been a Raiders fan so I
was a kid and people are like well you
still gonna be a family go to Vegas I'm
like yeah I have to be because I became
a fan when they were in LA when I was
growing up in San Diego so it'd be
hypocritical of me to say no just
because they're leaving Oakland I'm not
gonna be a saying anymore but oh yeah
I'm actually gonna be out there next
week Fred two weeks Fred Biletnikoff the
famous Hall of Fame receiver for the
Raiders he's having a golf tournament
and he invited me out to be one of the
one of the people I mean he's got a Hall
of Fame people Jerry Rice is gonna be
there and a bunch of his former teammate
it's house you like actually how's your
golf game Scott I get to act like a
celebrity firm how's your golf game
Scott can you can you hit it
can you really drive it what uh I mean
you gotta like it you got some long as
Club my putting honey they're awful
pudding or actually a really good
there's no rhyme or reason I don't play
enough drain everything you're like yeah
I'm good at this and then actually nine
times you play it's garbage yeah yeah I
love it good enough to have fun but I'm
bad enough to not keep score and not
care about it so yeah hey week on on
Quran in Cambodia beautiful wasn't it's
nice
I loved it over there fish it light up
at night yeah one of the producers woke
me up one time cuz he was like I think
you're the only one that would care
about this looked at and I walked over
and ours wasn't the fish it was the
algae that [ __ ] yeah the waves were
breaking and the algae was light up lit
up it was the coolest thing man bubbles
up one other person and they're like
yeah whatever man why'd you wake me up
it's just a once-in-a-lifetime thing I
thought maybe you'd enjoy they light up
like lightning bugs like so they can
find each other is it like a mating
thing it's algae I'm talking about
dinner was and it is it's it's a it's a
thing so the algae king whatever it's
it's not radioactive everything
bioluminescence only a few places no
Rico that's crazy-looking but dead on
this game yeah that's crazy
Scott any other sport you know to USC
got the big NFL draft in two days oh
yeah you excited about raft are you
gonna watch the draft what do you are
you excited about I mean like this is
such an interesting draft you guys I
care I care
yeah that's not true at all beyond the
Fox what are you talking about of course
everybody cares it's on foxes yeah
they're gonna in Fox ESPN but now it's
gonna be on Fox on on the regular
channel not the Fox by the way I hate
how they bus around over I hate I wish
they go back to how they used to do it
it sucks having a weight of like three
days to watch get to the last to the NFL
to milk that [ __ ] thing for milk it
like Scott John Stockton Scott Johnson
would just like Scott don't need Pollard
[ __ ] give me [ __ ] too are you you
have to see a guy are you UFC guy to you
have seen so much in the UFC I was
really disappointed to see what Connor
did when he did that was just dumb but
yeah I've been to a few of the fights I
like watching it and they're actually
you know I never was a fighter in my
whole life but being as big and strong
as I am I've never been scared out in
public you know like if somebody wants
to start some [ __ ] with me I figure I
can handle myself I've never been in a
fight I don't plan on be anyone but I
you know I've never really been scared
but then I started watching the UFC I'm
like yeah I'm certainly not gonna just
take off pick pick on some dude that
looks like he's half my size cuz he
might know how to rip my face off right
yeah that's not him you don't know who's
a trained anymore so you can't just like
go by size
I know he's not Commodores that's why no
you haven't trade for [ __ ] cuz you're
running from me like time it's like I
want to fight you forever fine do it do
it
[ __ ] I do like Aaron says you got to
look for cauliflower ear that's your toe
right you guys fight I Far East Side
fight are you do you still want to fight
this guy I told you guys to fight it
yeah hold on I'll fun now fight are you
gonna fight like boxing or MMA oh you
guys are good you guys gonna wear like
little leotards okay I hope so no I'm
gonna make we gotta go NATO field naked
advantage no no I know what those yeah
gizzards
Tom Johnson speaking of MacGregor I saw
a thing on on Twitter it said title that
a steep a posted music it goes a title
defenses for Mighty Mouse ten title
defenses for steep a music three title
defenses for Conor McGregor zero yes
never defended at a belt with all the
hoopla we got to hear about this guy
I've never started abating
I think he's fading I do too Ellis mania
is the end of September by the way 29th
and 30th of September yeah what about it
art you watch that movie yeah I thought
it was really good I really like oh yeah
you say good yeah like I don't want to
paint a picture but based on that it
looks like he's already got some health
issues like his knees are bad yeah
you're not gonna be a great UFC fighter
if your knees are messed up yeah part of
me thinks that that really was more of
an insight to what it's like to be a
fighter like I think they all got little
things going on here and there oh for
sure but it's the kind of training that
you're doing there you're you know it's
so rough on you training that's why so
many people miss miss fights because
they get injured during training camp
right you compare that to other major
sports baseball basketball football it's
pretty rare not rare but it's it doesn't
happen that much where somebody gets
injured in practice and then they're out
for a while you know where an MMA it
happens [ __ ] for every fight card
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm excited
we did our live UFC viewing party people
loved it I'm very are you in the
baseball at all Scott I watched my son's
fifth grade team Joe ah a lot of a lot
of money on the line yeah you don't
doubt any bets on that I would but they
just had their first game and they're
not very good so now I got to figure out
a different way too bad I can't can't
gamble on win-loss yeah that money
appears pants yeah the third inning you
know I got a bet on stuff like that cuz
I lose every game Jason come on friend
of ours Jason Glen has a funny joke
about watching his you know he has like
a fifth-grade daughter it he's like I'm
watching her soccer game and the coach
finally puts my daughter in do the voice
man come on Dean said the [ __ ] coach
puts my daughter in finally and I had to
go up to the coach and be like dude take
her out I got money on this game she
sucks that's great you gotta take her
out I'll go to one maybe game a year
whether it's semi-pro or pro and I enjoy
it but I couldn't sit and watch like
season tickets or even ten games a year
it's just not my sport what's the what's
the minor league team down there San
Diego he's an indie there isn't a minor
league team right there's a couple
writer on my Indiana dude if you could
live anywhere why Indiana's from sending
you three kids with my first wife and
joint custody Wow respect that is I
respect that I respect that
you can't commute to that job you know
it's pretty expensive
yeah it's tried it from Kansas cuz
that's where I consider Kansas whole
uh-huh let's turn it for Kansas for a
while and it just got old I put a lot of
miles on my truck and I ended up
realizing I had a house in Kansas and a
house in Indiana and that's just stupid
on any list yeah are you gonna get into
coaching at all no I
I've coached my son's fifth grade
basketball team but the coaching thing
is is that that lifestyle is tough man
they're gone just as much as the players
and then when they're home they're in
the office working way more than the
players but watching film and scouting
and all that stuff job security sucks
I'm a family guy and and and if somebody
would offer me a job I would consider it
as a be a coach but but most likely I
would choose family over that I've done
it so far and I've paid millions and
millions of dollars to my ex-wife for
the luxury of being in my children's
lives so I don't think that I'm gonna
leave that millions of dollars or make
some money and she can't
one layup hmm she hasn't she hasn't
boxed out she alone oh yeah kind of
[ __ ] world do we live in what about
the podcast Scott are you enjoying that
how's that going
I'm having fun because it's like therapy
for me here you know you guys are
sitting around talking about this and
that and and it's therapeutic I know you
yeah you can see the chemistry that you
guys have and and it's fun and it's
enjoyable and I get all my brain
droppings out it so that's a George
Carlin term but yeah you know what I
when I'm doing my podcast I get all my
brain draft things out and it's
therapeutic for me to be able to tell
stories and and my friends were you know
they're sitting around they're like man
you need to do a podcast I said why it's
just my life they're like yeah but no
one gets to know all the stuff that you
you've lived you've lived a weird life
man yeah we are
so I've never been that full of myself
but I am now because I'm doing a podcast
and pretty much all I do is talk about
myself the whole time right doing it
I've got about 14 15 episodes I just
started three months ago when did you
realize you had it's on iTunes
SoundCloud my last one was I had Ray
Allen on and before that I had Michael
Rapaport so I I cover all beaches I
don't just talk about sports I talk
about whatever I feel like talking about
last and it's been fun cuz you know I
actually did some stand-up comedy
recently oh [ __ ] and that's been fun too
how you go let's hear one yujeong
crackers here in town yeah style before
with the bell-bottoms of the law and the
[Music]
bees like every other dude that works at
Starbucks
what was your opening joke dude was your
opening joke what was
it's my dog hike humor you know like
people when I go out in public they're
like hey watch your head big guy I'm
like I've been tall since I was born I
was two feet tall when I was born had to
duck to get out of my mom is a good joke
yeah well Scott we appreciate you coming
on the show dude well Scott we
appreciate you coming on the show all
when you're in Los Angeles we'd love to
have you on absolutely
ah become in studio we'd love to have
you here and I would love it I might be
there in next month but I'm not sure
because then you know it's not like I'm
in a bed naked naked yeah you would love
to lay in a bed with a naked guy
wouldn't you Scott oh god its powers its
planet Pollard and you can find it all
planned Pollard podcast it's wonderful
pot and we appreciate you coming on your
more if you have anything you want to
push ever please come back on the show
you were great ma'am thanks buddy take
care of up ah guys real quick we are if
you want to bet on anybody's kids games
you can go to bet DSi bet the aside for
all your bet needs that's right bet DSi
go to the website Betty side comm use a
promo code punch 25 and you will get $25
or double whatever deposit you put in
that's right double whatever deposit you
put a couple people hit some parlay is
on the lat
UFC fight night the other day they
tweeted at me so congratulations that
thank you for using the code you could
bet on anything going to baseball right
now everything based on footy game I'll
go to the footy game yeah how great is
netball have you seen any highlights of
netball it's just hot chicks and
miniskirts playing basketball it's so
white and it's so
great it's like Ultimate Frisbee but
with basketball like like Ultimate
Frisbee re you can't move once you get
the ball but with basketball um hey Ari
what are your date's out the gates I
mean I'm in Australia for another couple
of weeks Adelaide on Thursday and then
Sydney on Friday Saturday than Brisbane
on Tuesday yeah I know nothing it's
depending on the Memorial I'm like home
beads do deal from there on Tuesday
they said they said when that is
tentatively oh I've been said in that
big that's why I'm not doing it I am
going to be June first I'm at Cobbs
comedy club in San Francisco for the
tinfoil hat comedy night myself Eddie
Bravo Trez mala and my man Ryan Davis
off the grid we are doing one show in
San Francisco June 1st and in another
show June 2nd in Sacramento tickets are
flying please grab them so what's going
on is whoever brings the most people
sells the most tickets you get to come
backstage smoke we ready Bravo do a
private podcast and then I just got hit
up by somebody who wants to take the
whole show and a limo ride to a weed bar
strip bar so you will join us join us
there and that's all it and a lot of
great we're editing my special right now
so hopefully that will be done soon
how's it look I love it I hate looking
at myself but I've seen a little bit
that room looks great there right yeah
man it would yeah it's great I like the
faraway shot because I hate looking at
myself but it looks great and I'm very
excited to tiny room the audio is great
a lot of big things come out you hear
some good news coming up on some other
stuff so I'm excited I'm gonna be at the
store this week we're gonna be at skank
Fest in July from what I understand I
will not be there okay and I'm going to
be at the not so okay saloon in West
world so that can't go
say I'm a host dude the host does the
most time there it's a weird Club they
also get killed
yeah they open up with an hour and then
they get killed by the feature and
watched it yet that I did that's where I
that the the black chicken a man she'd
she's so hot tonight no and then they
killed all black you know what that was
the her she was in this movie with Jon
Bon Jovi in like the mid 90s and it was
one of the first things I recorded on
VHS you know and I think it's just like
permanently and then they killed that
kid at the end so spoiler alert yeah I
don't think they're that kid who is the
really the boss yeah what's that all
right there's a new season last one just
came out first episode was last night
I'm excited what's happening Sam is out
on skank fest yeah I can't no you can't
make it you can't make it huh yeah why
just can't make it this year just can we
promote the date that you're doing
instead I'm gonna be with family it's a
family time it's oh it's at corporate is
it a corporate family
it must be spending time with family
it's my one time of year I know yeah one
thing we learned about with our guests
by the way he was great yeah is that
Mormons are fundamentalist Mormons are
Mormons are fundamentally sound at
basketball yeah more his dad all of his
brothers and him all played Division one
college basketball or higher yeah hard
that is five people in his family
including himself played high-level
Division one or professionally guys who
went was the elite they were number one
entire season one-loss team and then
they got beat by Arizona and not the
Elite Eight who went on to win it that
wasn't like Mike Bibby was there and
whatnot do you ever see this video these
morons schooling these guys my dad are
almost all athletes this question when
once there but I couldn't the
connections are good enough yes they're
done
I don't know what's their light
how does a life change after that like
you know when you everything you are is
a basketball player for [ __ ] 15 years
they say athletes died two deaths
sounds like once he's done yeah once he
was done he just started writing checks
to his ex-wife banging Asians from that
point on just banging Asia's I mean dude
he's seven foot these Asians are five
seven so the basically wind socks on his
dick right yeah you got a head like some
furniture for that or something right
like do their vaginas have to be like
Boas where they just unlock their
function their jaws just swallow right I
I don't know would you want to be that
tall yeah I want to play pro basketball
I want to bang down low I want to talk
mad [ __ ] the black guys I mean if I was
gonna be a professional athlete if I
wasn't it's probably it's bad for your
health to be probably rougher life yeah
well you could be any position
professionally what would it be in the
NBA any position in any sport huh oh boy
I don't know man outfielder no I mean
you could probably make the most money
with the least amount of work playing
baseball yeah I mean it's a ruling my
knees and everything I know what it's
like it's not like it your head kicked
in 7:30 you gotta be there at 5:30
you're your home I live in you're not
home you're on the road all the time you
may be a quarterback kicker I'd like to
be a kicker of all positions
professional sports you know I mean if
you're looking at like my dream position
like Rasheed Wallace type power for
point guard that's answer he uh he was
at the store the other day where she was
he's giant dude he's hilarious giant
dude I love you hair that change from
asking
yeah yeah yeah you mean the weird spot
the weird spot yeah for sure dude point
guard would be fun
maybe golfer golfer is a good golfer
okay walk away you're like a lot of
money like planted a Gala Ball fur we
smoked and drank yeah sure that's gonna
be any sport officer good gonna take
advantage of all the [ __ ] fun of it
how the show's been re all right I think
we lost them or that's the longest you
never how are the shows so it's pretty
good man
it's been pretty [ __ ] cool but it's a
vessel here so there's a lot of drinking
a lot of drink oh yeah you look hung
over
yeah no I didn't drink yesterday but I
was asleep at like 11:00 PMS oh look
who's up also late 11:00 p.m. what are
you burning the candle both ends after
that you just couldn't do it
a lot of drinking a lot of boning and
these Australian chicks yeah what about
the Australian chick sorry how's it
going no [ __ ] Australian chicks why
why why I don't know this one I was born
to and then we were like taxi back and
forth all hot about this one video and
then I was like you have anything to
sort I know and then she's like
obviously I was never gonna [ __ ] I just
wanted to see we just oh that's not nice
hey hey real quick down Anna oh [ __ ] hey
can you read some of your dirty talk do
you still have it in your phone you read
some no please - oh yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna tongue your book you please read
Emily you likes a kosher diner I'm
inside your [ __ ] and there's some matzo
soup I hope you like [ __ ] it look
like someone stuck a firecracker in a
double cheeseburger alright do you prep
a woman if she's not gonna go back do
you do any kind of prep like buttes warn
them before they take a
look at the the Juke Lambo
you said he had a long butt hole oh boy
a long butt hole is a funny [ __ ]
visual she was cool the cheddar [ __ ]
are you store a Star Wars fan I can't
imagine how you're gonna spin this into
black I'm listening
I've been seeing this ad for the Han
Solo movie and it's really pissing me
off
why does Han Solo's a [ __ ] like they
made him so [ __ ] small
it doesn't even like he comes up there
like Chewbacca's nuts
yeah well Chewbacca is like seven foot
six but still it's like he's so much
smaller than than like Harrison Ford
it's like they didn't even try I think
it looks good pretty pretty bad together
got some girl she was like a stunning
submitted looking guy to be the [ __ ]
evil but he took off his helmet I mean I
wish the producers [ __ ] who's the guy
from lost whatever his name is we made
lost and made Star Wars oh wow JJ Abrams
J James I wish he could hear in the
theaters just the fear of laughing what
he'd like yeah so stupid it's just like
that's just LA you know who's ran when
you see Magic Mike at the Oscars you
know who runs Hollywood fat chicks and
gay guys am i right dude am i right hey
do you guys remember when Scot Pollard
said I really knew my basketball I
remember we said the show really no
actually I don't remember that those
words were never your happy about giddy
I am they hit awesome they hit us up
they go hey man can you get sky on your
thing I'm like maybe who's they you know
publicists are realizing podcasts are
way to promote so that they're just like
yeah it's the new medias they like don't
reach out slow do ideas Joey Diaz is in
the news I'm dying up here the season
premiere of season 2 Oh is he
yeah plays a comic my mom's like a mafia
guy from Vegas trying to buy out the
funny scaling show please yeah why
wouldn't he play I mean I would love to
see a Greek oh yeah I can t be the mafia
guy
why can't he dude I know he did um guys
I think we should wrap it up I think we
had a good run Sam look at the model re
on the Sam Sam no dude you really know
what you're talking about did you play I
think he was actually talking to me
honestly cuz I had a little Larry Brown
comment and he was like you know you
guys are really [ __ ] smart I said
about the kids getting beat up he was
like dude inside guys thanks for all
your I see all the tweets everybody
keeps sending a love out to Dennis and
in Candace oh yeah baby they're doing
good everyone's happy everyone's healthy
so I want to give John Woodard a big
shout-out for all the hard work he's
done on the YouTube channel dude you're
crushing it Oh tubes we're really
watching the YouTube stories I'm really
seeing a lot of [ __ ] feedback not you
too dude you're doing great on it even
though I hate your titles Sam gets at
his ass handed to him by Ari you've got
it that's how you have to do it people
don't read them if he's gonna be
negative Sam if it's Sam knows it's
basketball no one's gonna listen to that
who wants to stand up no one will listen
to that only yeah that's exactly right
yeah that's how you do that though you
want you to watch it or not well go to
youtube.com backslash punch-drunk sports
and see all the stuff our pleasure
it's punch-drunk sports on youtube and
then the guys check out the patreon it
is rockin I do some MBA
stuff re like once a year does a some
extra stuff t-bone I've been doing I'm
gonna I got some footage from the footy
game
oh cool have explained to me though now
it's fuzzy yes three days ago there was
a score tied 73 73 tie game perfect dude
you see wait that was the final score
I'm looking up footies 40 games yeah you
can you can go to can you go to bet TSI
and make bets on it is it like a
professional big league I mean if they
have bets on stuff like that they're
like yeah the guys whatever use this for
the right thing he rubs it into
everybody I think I think you called him
out on it and then he was I better look
up footy right now I got to be rude guys
great podcast Tebow you crushing it
today we don't worry stopping community
I gotta take a break you guys take a
break finally got Ari on this show for
the first time in [ __ ] a month a
month you gotta take a [ __ ]
leave all your [ __ ] Sam he can't hear
you break are you leaving he's pub knows
and the door open this [ __ ] guy uh
Ari I got laid the other night and guess
what get this how thank you thank you
this girl this girl said the hottest
thing that you could say when you're at
the club right she goes well my flight
leaves at 4:00 p.m. tomorrow to go back
to Philadelphia and then you're like
it's early then the plot thickens
tonight um yeah yeah cuz I didn't even
meet her to like 11 when she was already
hammered oh that's right after you left
actually did the patreon ah man I missed
her huh
what tap she's taken back to the cubes
take it back to the bag of lead so did
you go to her place her share her hotel
nice Wow Hotel sex why not why not she
was like pretty cute too
she probably a Philadelphia eight like a
vacation situation what was she yeah she
was out here yeah just about in her life
like for some yeah get some comedy sport
of it's like at the Comedy Store her
last night and then she's like I'm gonna
get drunk and laid [ __ ] this town I'm
like I'm your huckleberry
[Laughter]
condom which is always a strike and but
not bad not bad
like a lot of get done [ __ ] around
before were [ __ ] was probably better
than them and how fast did you get out
of there I'm still shunned still lost a
in there no I just have the door I have
a wedge in the door no like I don't know
the next morning tennis that's good
whatever yeah cause she's leaving it for
you no you have to get up early yeah
exactly I just got up and bounced cool
so hey why not why not
hey guys Scott power thinks we're we
know a lot about basketball I don't know
if you heard that but I have heard that
okay alright and also thank you yeah two
point four two two point one how about
definitely say no and I didn't even have
one so I was gonna like maybe we can
just [ __ ] without one but then she had
one the window thanks to everybody for
for all the good comments we got from my
mom being on last week's episode as she
was right afterwards we went to to Jimmy
Kimmel how was that was super fun you
know but dombarris always hooks us up
and like got her backstage and we hung
out in the green room or it's
free food and free drinks and she got to
go on the stage meet the band that was
playing all that kind of [ __ ] man
Portugal the man she met the porch of
the man yeah yeah yeah like I don't hang
out with all damn it's super fun and
then Don just sexually harassed my mom
but my mom is so proud she made online
of those great because we're walking by
we're walking by like the crew and the
staff and Don's like singing my mom and
he goes hey to the staff he goes don't
don't talk to her she's married or she's
mine and my mom goes quick cock-blocking
me Barris he laughed at that she thought
that was pretty cool she's like I mean
I'm Barris laughs here's a photo so
thanks everybody for you nice comments
next time she's back she'll be here you
said is Latin Ibrahimovic was the guest
right you said he was pretty funny very
funny that soccer player all right it's
a lot tan or whatever that's any brahim
really funny and then one point in time
when you're there you can tell really
confident super funny guy you can tell
he's just super confident and almost to
the point of being funny almost like how
like Robert Downey jr. is in the Iron
Man movies yeah yeah and one point in
time so but when you're in the green
room you can see you're watching on the
screens it doesn't go to commercial
you're actually watching what's
happening in luggage so a lot of times
that's when Jimmy would be like hey
Denver hi Carolyn Sam next you know all
the news clips where he actually knows
the people's first names for the TV
affiliates around the country oh okay
Oh help knock out like ten of those in
between you know while we reckon well
that's really efficient really efficient
at a time to a science well so they're
not even just seeing their commercial
breaks like they're getting [ __ ] done
well the commercial breaks are there
he's like you know knock out a bunch of
those and then so one time he [ __ ] it
up and Kimmel goes I [ __ ] that up
and he goes fatuity on the steward again
and then that's all ten guy he goes you
wants me to do it for you and then
everybody laughed and applauded cause
he's like he's already so cocky it's
pretty funny going for you to do it for
you you know pro at that by now right
yeah it's like an old Magic Johnson it
seems like came to LA it came you know
here at like 36 or 37 to be like I'll
come out oh I make him away at that job
but oh by now I mean yeah he's great at
that job
when those guys come to America cricket
players or soccer players and their
massive around the world and they come
here and they're basically nobodies and
almost almost almost feel like oh you
should mind do the podcast like oh no
he's the biggest yeah and that's what he
was kind of talking about he's like you
know around the world you know what you
call soccer is like we're all bigger
than LeBron James
I mean richer and bigger yeah globally
except for here so I come here and it's
like I almost kind of have some
anonymity except for the major soccer
fans but you know when you get to go do
that and hang out with Don and thanks
thanks Don bears for allowing me to do
that you kind of go through this back
alley and you come in through there and
that's where like the talent like the
guests or the band and all that will
come in that way so but when we walked
out of there the line of people to dad
fenced off for him to sign things was
huge for Portugal the man nobody LL Cool
J was the other guest
nobody maybe a hundred people all in his
jerseys over soccer balls and sharpies
waiting for him to walk by exactly it's
a big soccer town and all of them are
either of his country or of his they all
had his professional Jersey on or they
were Mexican he's what sweet but they
were all here sweetest yeah or
Netherlands I think ninety sweet here is
he is swedish retsu swedish but a huge
line of people so he is popular it's
just you know we don't know a lot about
soccer unless you follow it out here all
right so you haven't heard anything
about it it just never got to the point
where they wanted it to it's getting
there well they [ __ ] themselves dude
they didn't make the World Cup
ninety-two not making the World Cup
really flatten it yeah they didn't make
it dude they're I mean terrible that's
right yeah probably great because this
year's in Moscow right that won't be
rigged at all that sounds like a real
safe place to go use your cell phone
yeah yeah as an American dude that's
that's like poison your doorknob and
just have their Olympic team couldn't
even
technically compete for a medal because
they were so breaking so many rules and
laws and now we're gonna have a World
Cup in Moscow huh
okay good bye Felisha
all right when are you back buddy it
just depends on I'm planning on coming
back for the memorial whatever it is
congratulations to come [ __ ]
and Janice on their new baby like
whatever the memorial is that that's all
be back so after after Brisbane what I'm
planning and doing is going to Cannes
and then going scuba diving for a few
days then in the Great Barrier Reef and
then I was gonna maybe go to Singapore
for a few days and then come come back
and stop by LA but I depends what it's
Memorial is yeah but you definitely go
hey hey alright don't don't tell Sam
because he won't come because he thinks
you're gonna pressure him to do the BET
so don't tell him just drop in don't
tell him when you're gonna be here cuz
he really I don't think he'll pop in
he's really worried about this yeah yeah
so don't tell him I was I mean how is he
gonna feel I've already seen fans I'm
not posting yet because he hasn't
officially he hasn't officially well
[ __ ] so I'm not posting but these fans
are they're gonna go crazy he's gonna
block them off he's already blocked you
have no idea they're gonna make stuff
I've seen Sam Tripoli's well welches we
see beautiful you not posting the stuff
I think makes him think he's getting
away with it though I think he thinks
he's getting away with it because you're
not like pressuring him right I really
do
anyway so he's out on skank fest he says
the Ellis mania is the end of September
if you can do that oh dude it's booked
missus bet
of course oh really
yeah of course it is hmm interesting
don't you think
I mean I'll come I'll do it without we
can do a sorry and I can do a puncheon
without him that forms due to it what
happened
I think he thought that you might have
to stick in his ask just family stuff
I'm like that's weird
that's see what you wouldn't you said a
wedding or a reunion or something like
yeah you don't have any extra detail do
you because you're just making it up
yeah he looked at me long time I think
he's time yeah yeah wait so he you were
great he does not have a family oh of
course not have no idea this first I
heard that he wasn't going no last I
would be a good way to [ __ ] market
ourselves to a new audience base I'll
talk to him after that formed Eminem's
dude in New York - what that form is due
today
what did you say robot for was what I
the form the deadline for submitting
yeah if we're submitting it's today I
don't know if that's a hard deadline or
whatever familiar yeah dude he he
doesn't want to stay a hotdog in his ass
it's almost certainly why I kind of do I
feel like I practice all those months
free why don't you be like his Jesus
Christ you know just take his sins on
and stick the hotdog up your ass
uh-huh oh I could get like stigmata with
hotdogs through my hands you can nail me
to a wall with [ __ ] dogs when it push
comes to shove it's like I couldn't
imagine not going maybe if you guys
clean up those other bets first it'll
put more pressure on him but I really
don't have it I mean he can that's
always his go-to argument ours are
relatively easy to do yeah I do
then his go-to arguments toast I mean
he's done my training one takes a lot
away but you do it here we get it on
video you haven't be begging I can get
the bank only have a couple days in LA
but yeah I could do it okay I get it
back I'm done there's no video for the
beggar take me [ __ ] days Shia I still
let me get some shots from across the
street or something that would be great
let you get some shots but like it's
gonna take me a long time the USA thing
that's I'm gonna try to get a video of
it like my plan is get on the subway
like they got Assad Assad got killed
everybody my friend go I saw got killed
Isis surrender yeah you have someone
else the subway ready for the whole
thing uh-huh
good plan I mean there's no video I'm
just going for you can argue that two of
us you and you and I the bets that we
have lingering we could both go to jail
like it'd be funny if our he's doing the
homeless one and I call the cops I don't
know like there's this [ __ ] homeless
guy outside harassing people but I could
very well go to jail for my [ __ ] one
that can really think I'm like being a
hooker or I could get beat up by
[ __ ] in certain states you could get
arrested for the hot dog thing - not
this one not this one well like Utah I
mean yeah probably Georgia Georgia yeah
Aaron who's after us oh it's really
fancy uh whoo it's tinfoil of course no
wonder oh that's why that's why as a
podcast he cares about he has a podcast
that he cares about coming up all right
let's go outside and just look at Sam
[ __ ] you're talking to somebody outside
yeah well we got to wrap up anybody cuz
it's a pretty much 5 are you I miss you
buddy I can't wait till you're back in
town it'd be good to see ya are you on
next week re are you on the next
Tuesday's episode for his been night
yeah or yeah yeah okay okay man y'all we
got you our guest will be but that'll be
cool as always go to bed TSI calm music
code punch 25 please peruse our friends
at SeatGeek dot-com or get the app user
code punch right there that gets you 20
bucks off of any tickets that you
purchase and as always thank you to
everybody good luck to fight nany and
Aaron thank you suck it